six mois de préparation pour le nouveau
studio 6 millions lourdes équipements
électroniques et 60 secondes pour
visiter l'envers du décor et oui c'est
ici que se réalise en direct vos
journaux télévisés une heure et demie
par jour autant qu'un film de grand
spectacle
jean claude bourret au maquillage et
notre mascotte béatrice kaufmann avec
ses recettes derrière moi vous voyez un
carton et en fait il ya un truc dans
tout ça je vous montre et je vais vous
donner un exemple
ce soir nous allons avoir un grand dîner
à tour eiffel eh bien je vais vous
donner menu de ce grand dîner et oui ce
soir en réveillant avant leurs
langoustes champagne et luge de notes